The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: Feel
free to populate the front row.
I'm not that scary.
So today, we're going to look
at more greedy algorithms.
So I think you went
over Kruskal's algorithm
and how you do the
sorting in the lecture.
So going back to make
change from last recitation,
so this is sort of
a variant on that.
So instead of
discrete coins, we now
have continuous coins, in the
sense so the analogy here is,
let's say, you have N metals,
and each of the metals
has some value given by
Ci dollars per kilogram,
or whatever units you prefer.
And you want to
achieve some value
T. You want to give someone
T dollars worth of metal.
And you want to do this
while minimizing-- oh, so I
should mention this.
ki is the weight of
every metal that you
will give to the person.
So you're taking ki of metal
i, and you are going to--
and you have to ensure,
so basically, you
have to ensure that some
summation of ki Ci over all i
is equal to T. And in doing
so you want to minimize
the summation over all ki.
So does that make sense?
So you have a bunch of metals.
Some of them are more
expensive than others.
And you want to measure
them out and give someone
a certain fixed value.
So anyone have any
ideas how to do this?
Should be-- should be the
first thing that comes to mind.
So you have much of
metals-- some of them
with certain costs.
And you're trying
to create a value T.
So which metal would
you want to pick?
So it should seem
intuitive that if you
want to minimize the
weight of the metal,
you would want to pick
the-- have the most
expensive one for weight.
So let's start by sort by Ci.
And we want to sort it
in decreasing order.
Does make sense?
So if you have the
most expensive metal,
you want to use as much
of that as you can,
so that your weight
is minimized.
So once you sort by Ci, so
let's say, you have your costs
right now are-- let's call
this one C1, C2, up to Cn.
And these are in sorted order.
So it's increasing this way.
So you now take your value
T, and you look at T by C1.
And that is the amount of weight
you would need to generate C.
So you look at how
much you have here.
So the amount of metal-- so a
constraint I forgot to mention,
you are given a limited
amount of every metal.
OK, that's-- it's
not that trivial.
So you have--
let's mention that.
So you have-- is that used?
No, it's not-- amount.
Does that make more sense?
So you look at T over Ci.
And if T over Ci is
greater than W of i,
then you just use the amount
you need to construct Wi,
and you're done.
Otherwise, you use all of Ci.
So if it's less than
Wi, in that case,
you-- sorry, other way around.
If it's greater than
Wi, you use all of it.
And then you move on to the next
one, the next one, and so on.
So that seems pretty intuitive.
Let's actually do a
formal proof of that.
So how you go about
proving this is
that-- so let's say-- so it's
what we call the current base
method.
So basically what
you have is, let's
say you're not using the
most expensive metal you
have at this point.
So let's say your most
expensive metal has cost Ci,
but instead, you
decide to use Cj.
So let's say you decide to
use some kj amount of Cj.
So the value you're
getting from this is Cj kj.
And instead, if you use
Ci, how much metal would
you need to get the same value?
You would need Cj kj over Ci.
Does that make sense?
So this is the value you
would obtain by using
kj kilograms of this metal.
So if you instead used this
one, you'd get this value.
And so this is the
most expensive one.
And Ci is greater
than Cj, this value,
so this value is less than kj.
So by using this metal
instead of that one,
you are decreasing the amount--
the weight you would need,
so your minimization goes down.
Make sense?
So that's like a very
simple greedy algorithm.
And it's-- the algorithm is
exactly what you'd expect,
and the proof isn't very hard.
So let's move on to a
slightly interesting one.
So this is process scheduling.
So let's say you
have a computer,
and you're running
end processes.
And each of the process
has a time-- t1 through tn,
again processes.
And you want to order
them in some way.
So first, you will
do process p1.
Then you'll process p2,
and so on, and so forth.
Then you'll define
a completion time.
So completion time is simply
when does process i end.
So when does process i end?
You just p1 plus-- it's like
the time for p1 plus time for p2
up to pn.
So basically, you have
all your processes.
So let's says this is p1,
this is p2, and so on.
And the completion time for a
certain process in the middle
is just the sum of
all times before it.
That's completion time.
And now what you
want to do is you
want to minimize the
average completion
time, which is summation
over all the completion
times over n.
So any ideas what an algorithm
for this would look like?
Essentially, you
want to minimize
the sum of all these times.
So all these times, you want to
minimize the average of these.
So what do you want to do?
Do you want to shift the
slower-- the processes which
take more time, do you want
to keep them at the end,
or do you want to keep
them at the beginning?
So if you have a bunch
of small processes,
what do you do with
them at the end?
What do you do at the beginning?
Completion time
is when does-- So
let's say this is process pi.
And completion time for process
pi is like this distance.
It's like, when does
pi get completed?
So it's summation of all
the times-- so the time
taken for p1, p2,
up to the end, see?
So you want to
basically minimize
the average of these values.
So where do you put
the smaller processes--
would you put the
shorter processes
at the end or the beginning?
Which one would
decrease your average?
The beginning?
Makes sense, right?
So yeah, that makes sense.
So you basically
want to like scrunch
these lines towards
the beginning,
so your average is smaller.
Note that this total length
is always the constant.
It's like summation over all ti.
So let's go about-- so
OK, this is strategy.
Again, sort by ti, and
this is increasing order,
and that's it basically.
So this is your
algorithm, sorted by tn,
but use the process
in that order.
So let's try to prove this.
So the way you prove this
is a pretty generic method.
It is often used to
prove greedy algorithms.
So let's say that this
is not the optimal.
Let's say someone
comes up to you
and tells you, OK, I
have a better sequence.
I have a sequence,
let's say, called--
let's say I have a
sequence of p1 to pn.
And that sequence does
better than a sorted order.
So you're like, OK, so
if this is not sorted,
then you have some
elements in the middle.
Let's say you call
them pi is greater
than pj, with i is less than j.
So there's some pi here, and
there's some pj here, such
that this is greater than that.
So it's not in sorted order.
So you can always
find a pair like that.
So now I'm going to claim
that if you swap these two
values-- so you swap pi
and pj-- that'll actually
decrease whatever current
average completion time you
have.
So initially, you had
something like this.
So-- no, let's not
draw a line there.
So let's say you had something
like you had this process, so
pi-- actually, this is the
bigger process, so this is pi,
and this is pj.
And now I'm saying
that-- and you
have some stuff in the middle.
And my claim is that,
no, this is not optimal.
You'd do much better if
you moved the pj over here.
So you want to go from this
to this, and big process.
So let's see what changes when
you go from there to there.
So first of all, observe
that the completion
times of everything
behind this is the same.
They all have the
same completion time;
nothing is affected.
And you're only changing
these two things.
Everything after this
is also the same--
has the same completion time.
So the only things
that are changing
are this one, this one, and
all the ones up to this one.
Even this one has the
same completion time.
Make sense?
So how much is this changing by?
So let's define this.
Delta is equal to t
of pi minus t of pj--
so the difference between
these two processes.
So the original completion
time of pi was this.
And now the
corresponding process
down here, the completion
time is decreased by delta.
So completion time for us
goes down like minus delta.
This is a summation
of completion time.
This divided by n is a constant.
So you just want
to minimize this.
So first it goes-- so this
one goes down minus delta.
So let's look at
the next process.
The next process is
something like this.
So again, these do not change.
You're only swapping these two.
So this completion time
also down a minus delta,
and so on, and so forth.
So you just get a
bunch of minus deltas,
which is equal to however
many processes you have.
But that's not even important.
What is important is
that just by swapping,
you're going to get at
least one minus delta.
And delta is positive, because
assumption-- oops, sorry,
t-- because assumption was that
t pi minus t pj is positive.
So just by swapping, you're
going to always decrease it.
So the claim that that sequence
was an optimal solution
is wrong.
So you can always do better
by swapping two inversions.
So that out of sorted order
is called an inversion.
So if you solve an inversion,
you always get a better result.
Does that proof make sense?
So that's a slightly more
interesting recent algorithm.
So let's move on to the
third one we have here.
The third one is event overlap.
So this is how it works.
So you wake up in the morning,
and you look at your calendar.
And being an MIT student, your
calendar looks pretty full.
So let's say this is
what it looks like.
So these are your events.
Let's use some colors, make
it a little clearer possibly.
And let's say you have
another event over here.
You have something here.
And you have something here.
So OK, let's move this down.
So the problem is that
you have this bunch
of events planned out.
Now clearly,
they're overlapping,
so you can't attend all of them.
So the idea is you make a
bunch of clones of yourself.
And so in this case, look
at the matching colors.
So if you create clone
number 1 goes here,
and clone number 2 goes
to red, and clone number 3
goes to blue.
So then clone
number 1 does this.
Clone number 3
does the blue one.
Clone number 2 does red.
I guess, we should move
the red back a little
or forward a little bit
just to make it clear.
Yeah, there we go.
And now, you could easily
see that this is optimal.
So you can do this with
three clones and no less.
So you make three
clones, and then you
can go off to spring break.
And your schedule is fine.
So now, how would you
approach this problem?
So what is a greedy strategy
to, given a number of intervals,
how do you find the
minimum number of clones
you need to cover your day?
Any ideas?
What is a naive
thing you could do?
AUDIENCE: When you
say to cover your day,
then it's like the number--
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: So
you want to do every event.
But like so this clone can't--
so clone number 1 does this
event.
Then he can't do this
event or this event.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
maximizing your events?
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: You
want to do all the events?
You want to minimize
the number of clones.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS: So
it's like interval scheduling.
But you want to do
all the intervals,
but you're allowed to
use multiple people
to do all the intervals.
Yes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could
sort by end time.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS:
By end time, OK.
What do you do after
you sort by end time?
AUDIENCE: And then iterate
over all the intervals
once they're sorted and just
count how many intervals there
are between the [INAUDIBLE].
That would get complicated.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS:
So you're close.
So you do begin by sorting.
But you can actually do
it by sorting by end time.
It's easier to visualize
if you sort by start time.
So leading from that,
anyone want to top in?
AUDIENCE: It's when
your sorting starts,
and every time you get a
class, you get a new clone.
AMARTYA SHANKHA BISWAS:
So yeah, essentially,
every time you can't add it
to one of your current clones,
you just create a new one.
You could also do
it by end time,
because it's symmetrical, right?
So if you sort by
end time, then you
start with the smallest-- last
end time and go backwards,
exactly the same thing.
So let's write it down.
So sort by start
time, and so actually,
let's work out this example.
So in this case, you
would go-- OK, actually,
if once you sort--
so first you have 1,
then you have 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So that's sorted by start time.
And then you have-- so
first you go for this one.
Then you go for 2, and
2 intersects with 1.
So you put 2 into it.
So this is clone number 1.
And then you have to
create a new clone for 2,
so you create the new clone.
And there we go.
So then you go to 3.
3 clashes with both
1 and 2, so you
have to create a
new clone again.
So in that case, you
go forth and create 3.
Then you go to 4.
Now, 4, you see, it's
starts with 2 and 3,
but it is good with 1.
So you just put 4 over here.
And if you continue like
this, you essentially
get this and this.
Make sense?
So that's how you schedule it.
So does that
algorithm make sense?
Let's try to prove
its correctness.
So let's look at the instance
where you're inserting
the m-th clone-- so m-th clone.
So when the m-th is
created, you already
have some values in here.
So you have 1, 2, all
the way up to m minus 1.
So now, you bring
in your interval,
and you see that it collides
with all of these values.
So let's just draw the final
interval for all these guys.
So let's say the final interval
for this guy was out here.
Let's say the final
interval for this guy
was out here, and so on, and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And so when you
create the m-th clone,
you look at the start time.
So what happens is that the
start time is somewhere,
let's say, here.
And now, you know
that because of this--
so you're only adding
a new clone when you
don't have an available slot.
So that means that there
is some interval here,
which intersects with this guy.
So how do you show that
this is one interval?
Well, it's like
consider any level.
But say there is no interval
that intersects with it.
So that means that
there is either-- So
if there were a gap here-- so
let's say, at this location,
this interval wasn't here.
Let's say if you extrapolate
this line outward-- so this
is your current starting value.
And let's say you
look at this line.
And in this segment,
you can't have
something which
starts after this,
because this is the current
highest sorting starting time.
So there's no interval
that starts after this.
So the only interval
that's going to exist
have already ended here.
And if they're
already ended here,
that means you
could evaluate here.
Does that make sense?
So basically, then
you can show that, OK,
so at every existing-- if
you're adding a new clone, that
means at every
existing level, you
have something which intersects.
So what that means
is that you have
a single point of
time where there
are m minus 1 plus 1 intervals.
That means that you absolutely
need m intervals regardless
of what your strategy is.
So adding the m-th
clone is necessary.
So if you go on,
continue the argument--
let's say your total
number of clones
was m-- so you can just
do this argument for m.
There you will show that, oh,
if I followed all these rules
correctly, I can show
that the start time for m
intersects with m minus
1 other intervals.
So there's no way I
can create a scheduling
with less than m clones.
Did that argument make sense,
or should I go over it again?
So that's somewhat hand wavy,
but that shouldn't be-- OK.
In any case, well, that's
the three problems.
So I guess we can
go back to this one
and sort of give the
motivation for this.
So this could, for example, be
used in scheduling processes
for servers, for instance.
So let's say your server gets
a request to run n processes,
and they have times like that.
So this is like
shortest time first.
So you take all the
short-- the smallest jobs,
and you execute them
in the beginning.
And you wait for other jobs.
And this can also
be done online.
So you can have an
online version of this.
So if you take this algorithm
and you do it online-- so let's
say your server is running
jobs, and you get a new request.
So you get a new request, so
you already have some set of t1
to tn.
And let's say, at
the current moment,
ti is your smallest job.
And you're running it, and
you're currently at this point.
And then in the
middle of running it,
you can get new
requests for jobs.
So how would you modify this
algorithm to handle that?
So you still want to maintain
this lowest average completion
time thing.
So how would you
handle this situation.
So let's say you're
in the middle of a job
and you get a bunch
of new requests.
So current set is all
these existing jobs
plus some other things
you get in here.
So would you consider switching
to a different job here,
or would you keep doing this?
Let's say one of the new
jobs you get is really small.
So what you would
do in that case
is that instead of
continuing with this,
you would switch to
current smallest job.
So you would look
at the remaining
time, so that's important.
So you could forget
about the amount of time
you already spent on this.
You know what the
remaining time is,
and that is all
that is relevant.
So you can just
consider this problem
in a different framework.
It's the exact same question.
You just look at remaining
time, instead of total time.
So if you're in the
middle of a job,
and a new one comes
in which is smaller,
you just switch to
that, complete that,
and then look at the remaining
times for everything.
So at some point
of time, you might
have a lot of half completed
jobs just lying around.
And for all of them, you'll
update their ti values
to remaining time
rather than start time.
And that gives you
a nice way to decide
which processes to do online.
And that gives you--
So this is assuming that all of
your tasks have equal weights.
So all of them
have equal reward.
So obviously, that's
not always the case.
You might be pushing back
a very long job forever,
because smaller
things keep coming in
and that might get important.
But everything is
equally weighted,
then this is the optimal
thing you can do.
And it's a very simple
strategy that works.
So those are the three
problems I wanted to discuss.
Do you guys have any other
questions or comments
or anything?
Good?
OK.
We finished pretty
early, so I guess,
have a great spring break.